[Musique]
on doit aussi tirer les enseignements de
ce qui s'est passé il ya six mois c'est
à dire un état qui qui réagit dans
l'affolement général en ascension pas
les collectivités territoriales en
associant pas les organisations
professionnelles
eh bien on arrive à des décisions qui
sont incomprises et inefficace j'aurais
attendu 10 attendue des annonces sur la
question des tests la politique de tests
qui est un chaos le plus total
essayez de vous faire tester chiffre
prouve malheureusement que le
gouvernement ne maîtrise pas totalement
la situation sanitaire c'est surtout
leur dire d'arrêter avec cet ultra
centralisation et de faire croire que la
situation est sous contrôle et qu'on
travaille évidemment avec les élus
locaux vous rendez compte qu'à marseille
personnes avaient été prévenus ils ont
discuté mais à aucun moment il avait été
envisagé est dit très clairement que les
bars fermerait définitivement en tout
cas définitivement qui fermerait
totalement donc cette méthode de
gouvernance n'est plus possible
actuellement dans le cadre de cette
crise sanitaire situation est grave un
certain nombre de services que ça soit
d'urgence ou de réanimation sont dans
des niveaux de saturation important déjà
déjà le gouvernement at il eu raison de
prendre les mesures qu'il a prises
en tout cas il a eu raison de prendre
des mesures moi je trouve j'espère que
nous allons pouvoir en parler que ces
mesures sont en réalité toujours en
retard d'un train depuis le mois de mars
réfléchissons bien quand même à ce que
les mesures soient comprises intégré
accepté est jugé acceptable par nos
compatriotes plus les mesures seront
sévères et restrictive mois elles seront
comprises accepté et moi nos
compatriotes se les approprient rond et
plus pour le coup on ira au devant de
graves divisions les républicains j'ai
fait partie de ceux là j'étais l'auteur
d'une loi en octobre de l'année dernière
qui a été votée en décembre de l'année
dernière qui généralise et le bracelet
anti rapprochement ça le bracelet anti
rapprochement c'est pas le l'amande
parce que vous avez si fait quelques
dans la rue c'est quelque chose de
beaucoup plus important c'est de choses
qui permet de protéger les femmes qui
sont en danger de mort et ça compte
beaucoup plus que les déclarations à
sous de marlène schiappa la loi a été
votée en décembre de l'année dernière
elle devait être appliquée cette
généralisation du bracelet anti
rapprochement en janvier c'est ce que la
garde des sceaux nous avait expliqué en
janvier on nous a dit finalement ce sera
en juillet et en juillet on nous a dit
finalement ce sera en septembre nous
sommes le 22 ou 23 septembre aujourd'hui
il n'y a toujours pas le déploiement des
bracelets anti-rapprochement dans notre
pays le président de la république sur
ce sujet de l'islamisme radical d'abord
mais n'arrive pas à prononcer le nom
c'est une réalité
liddell les victimes aujourd'hui plus de
260 victimes depuis depuis 2012 ils sont
pas victimes de je ne sais trop quel
séparatisme ils sont victime de
l'islamisme radical
le président de la république est
incapable de se prononcer sur ce sujet
il arrive pas pour non seulement tous
les trois mois il nous annonce un grand
discours le séparatisme qui est
désormais le mot que nous devrons
employer puisque c'est la volonté du
président de la république qui réfute le
mot communautarisme et bien si nous
voulons véritablement lutter contre le
communautarisme je préfère ce terme qui
est plus clair et bien il faut savoir à
certains moments prendre ses
responsabilités et dire nous une vraie
différence avec monsieur macron elle est
là c'est sa lâcheté face au
communautarisme islamistes ça fait
quatre ans trois ans et demi qu'il est
au pouvoir qui nous annonce un texte
pour combattre le communautarisme mais
n'en le séparatisme bref l'islamisme le
séparatisme n'a jamais aussi forts de
notre pays
on va de recul en recul de compromis en
compromissions et je vous dire les
séparatistes et les communautarismes ont
très bien compris cela parce qu'ils
savent très bien que le gouvernement est
faible et donc leur idéologie se propage
le drame est terrible le drame de voir
revenir
cette violence islamiste en plein paris
pourquoi revient tel parce que nous ne
nous sommes pas donné les moyens
d'éradiquer les coups vous voulez dire
que c'est et on renoue avec la victoire
pour ce qui est de la droite nous avons
gagné les municipales c'est à dire que
sur le les élections territoriales les
français on fait confiance aux candidats
de droite et notamment candidats les
républicains et les élections
sénatoriales c'est le prolongement serre
que l'on gagne 10 sièges au sénat
ça n'est pas rien ça n'est pas
anecdotique et c'est ce qui va nous
permettre de nous préparer aux autres
échéances territoriales
républicain incarne ce choix cette
alternative entre ce duel que certains
veulent installer entre monsieur macro
et madame le pen moi je ne me résous pas
à avoir à faire ce choix parce que c'est
un choix qui n'est pas positif qui n'est
pas bénéfique pour notre pays jean
marche ça ne représente rien parce que
c'est un parti qui est coupé des
territoires qui n'a pas de racines ses
élus ils sont déconnectés la droite les
républicains c'est premier parti de
france
la droite on a le sentiment parfois
c'est jamais très bien ou très bon genre
que d'être de droite
moi j'assume d'être de droite je suis
pour l'autorité je brûle respectivement
de l'environnement je suis pour la
sécurité je suis pour la réduction des
inégalités inégalités je suis pour la
reconnaissance du mérite et du travail
ce qui n'est plus le cas aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui nous sommes une fois plus
sur le projet on peut pas courir deux
lièvres à la fois cours ont d'abord
après le lièvre du projet c'est pour ça
que nous avons lancé je vous le dis le
moi des idées que nous avons le tour de
france de l'environnement qui a
également été lancé au niveau des
républicains nous avons fait tous ses
forums thématiques depuis plus d'un an
tour de christian jacob à la peine alors
lucas
[Musique]